after fairing thus badly the enemy
departed while the Greeks continued
their march unmolested through the
remainder of the day and arrived at the
Tigris River here was a large deserted
City its name was Larissa and it was
inhabited in ancient times by the Medes
it's wall was 25 feet in breadth and a
hundred in height and the whole circle
of the wall was to Paris Ang's it was
built of clay bricks and rested upon a
stone foundation 20 feet high this city
was besieged by the king of the Persians
when the Persians were seeking to rest
the Medes from their empire but it could
in no way capture it a cloud however
overspread the Sun and hid it from sight
until the inhabitants abandoned their
city and thus it was taken nearby the
city was a pyramid of stone a plethora
min breadth and to plethora in height
and upon this pyramid were many
barbarians would flood away from the
neighboring villages from this place
they marched one stage six Paris Ang's
to a great stronghold deserted and lying
in ruins the name of this city was miss
Bella and it was once inhabited by the
Medes the foundation of its wall was
made of polished stone full of shells
and it was 50 feet in breadth and fifty
in height upon this foundation was built
a wall of brick 50 feet in breadth and a
hundred in height and the circuit of the
wall was six para sangs
here as the story goes Medea the King's
wife took refuge at the time when the
Medes were deprived of their empire by
the Persian
to this city also the king of the
Persians laid siege but he was unable to
capture it either by length of siege or
by storm Zeus however terrified the
inhabitants with thunder and thus the
city was taken